hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks so much for being with us
lock them up that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
all right rule of thumb liberals don't
care about crime unless it's committed
by people they don't like or people they
disagree with politically
remember they threw the book at the j6
defendants and many were given years in
jail
the judge also gave him quite a
significant sentence believing it too
amounted to a crime of domestic
terrorism seditious conspiracy and the
judge gave him 12 years Federal
prosecutors are recommending the
toughest January 6th sentence yet for
two leaders of The Proud boys 33 years
in prison
now some of the 2020 BLM rioters did
sometime but nothing like we're seeing
here because one protest was considered
legitimate and moral one illegitimate
and immoral
now the left accuses Republicans of
profiling criminals but the truth is
Democrats are themselves master
profilers
now who can forget back in 2006 when a
black woman accused three White Duke
lacrosse players of rape they were
prosecuted their lives destroyed but
ultimately they were all cleared of all
charges
their teammate their only black teammate
nailed what motivated the charges in the
first place basically telling Good
Morning America that it was because of
race
similar biases were on display more than
13 years later when the Press was
willing to come down on that Covington
Catholic Student Nick Sandman whose
moral crime was wearing that Maga hat
and looking forward when he was in town
for the March for Life this face-to-face
confrontation igniting charges of racism
a mob of Maga hot wearing high school
students surrounding a Native American
were kind of smirking at him and kind of
looking down their noses at him why do
we always do this in these sorts of
cases when white boys are involved we
give privilege to these white kids
of course if he were wearing a Planned
Parenthood hat and glaring at some poor
old pro-lifer none of those people in
the media would accuse him of menacing
looks or trying to intimidate an elderly
activist
of course not because it's all political
now imagine if the video you're about to
see involved two white teens laughing as
they mowed down a black former police
officer who was out riding his bike
caution this video is very disturbing to
watch
yeah yeah
this happened more than a month ago who
thinks that it would have taken this
long to release the video if the races
of the alleged perpetrators and the
victims were reversed
now we all know the answer to that and
look we still don't have the manifesto
of that trans killer in Nashville
we've been waiting for that how
convenient
crime is crime crime should be treated
as crime regardless of the race of the
criminals or their victims
but that's just not how the left sees it
and that's not how they ever want to see
it and this is part of the reason why
things are spinning out of control we
all see it we all know what's happening
with retail theft where billions of
dollars are lost annually to scenes like
this
and vicious cruel moments like this when
two teens just decide to lash out for
the hell of it
I go
[Laughter]
after years of demonizing police as
vicious racists the left feels no
responsibility whatsoever when police
officers are either gunned down or run
over as you saw earlier in that Las
Vegas clip
they're just simply wearing uniforms or
their past Association as a police
officer
this happened last week in LA
he was just driving down the street
and for no apparent reason and we're
still looking into the specific reasons
somebody decided
to shoot and murder him
I'm assuming at this point because he
was in uniform
that to me is sickening
yeah sickening all right and sickening
also described what we saw last week in
New York where it's not just police who
were being targeted but the vulnerable
elderly an 80 year old man named
Marcelino Valerio and his wife for
getting out of the car near their home
in the Bronx
when he was shot in the head and killed
looks like the murdering Thug was just
out trying to have some fun
the suspect who was dressed entirely in
Black including a black ski mask wrote
up next to Valaria on the sidewalk shot
him twice one of the shots striking him
point blank in the head
we've seen what more permissive
approaches to Crime did in the 1960s
when social upheaval plus the spread of
recreational drug use gave way to urban
riots and rise in crime
the violent crime rate in the 60s
increased 126 percent between 1960 and
1970. that's according to the pretty
liberal Brennan Center for justice
but the fact is tough on crime policies
worked when we had them and they were
attacked however as racist and unjust
and then they were ultimately ditched in
cities like New York
crime went up
now leftists may have been pleasing in
their conduct thrilled they were
thrilling The Faculty at Yale and
Columbia law school when they pushed
cities to pursue so-called bail reform
or ending stop and frisk but
it's nothing but doing the opposite of
what most people want they're putting
criminals back onto the streets
in the anti-law and Order crowd is so
fanatical they're moving full steam
ahead in fact today Illinois became the
first state in the nation to eliminate
cash bail completely
and this is Chicago is still in the
grips of violent crime but radical
politicians like the Speaker of the
House there Emanuel Chris Welch
celebrate
we've heard a lot of falsehoods about
this historic law we heard a whole lot
of racist dog whistles too
and we're still hearing them
but let's be clear
the pre-trial Fairness Act makes
Illinois a national leader in Criminal
Justice Reform and we are making our
communities safer
I'm gonna go off script for a moment who
thinks that's going to make Illinois
safer we'll check back in a year
meanwhile this is what is considered
good news in Chicago over the weekend 24
people were shot but no reported
homicides that was only the second
weekend that happened all year
but the fact is crime is going to
continue to rise and innocent people
will continue to be victims of it until
voters in urban America say enough is
enough and until those Suburban voters
also decide
that there's only one party out there
that's putting racial politics ahead of
safety and that's the Democrat Party
it's time to take a chance elsewhere
so I predict next year more women and
more minorities will choose safety and
Sanity over dangerous virtue signaling
gosh let's hope so and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else